le le Mouvement Démocrate donne la
possibilité de s'engager de plein de
[Musique]
façons bonjour je m'appelle Dimitri
Valentin j'ai 23 ans je suis adhérant
aux jeunes démocratees depuis près de 2
ans et actuellement stagiaire et
anciennement surveillant pénitentiaire à
la maison d'arrêt de fleur Merogis j'ai
un cap chauffeur routier et un Bac Pro
Logistique
par la suite j'ai commencé des études en
fac de droit avec plein de petits
boulots en parallèle que j'ai décidé
d'écourter pour m'orienter d'abord vers
un service civique au sein du tribunal
de Marseille et pour finir je me suis
engagé dans l'administration
pénitentiire la raison pour laquelle je
me suis engagé au modem c'est évidemment
parce que j'en partage beaucoup de
valeur j'en partage le dynamisme et
surtout j'en partage une vision de faire
la politique c'est dire non pas une
vision spectaculaire non pas une vision
bruyante mais une vision responsable et
une vision
intelligente donc moi ma première
interaction que j'ai eu avec le
Mouvement Démocrate ça a
été par l'intermédiaire des médias par
l'intermédiaire des journaux de mes
propres renseignement au moment où je je
cherchais à m'engager politiquement et
j'ai décidé de prendre des ivement ma
carte lors de l'université de rentrée à
Guidel en 2022 le le Mouvement Démocrate
donne la possibilité de s'engager de
plein de façons évidemment il y a les
tractages il y a plein de réunions en
interne on rencontre plein de gens
fabuleux qui nous permettent de
d'explorer d'autres d'autres horizons
d'autres points de vue sans jamais de
tabout ça c'est très important j'ai eu
l'occasion de participer à des soirées
débats organisé par le modem qui ont
permis de m'enrichir intellectuellement
de faire des rencontres et de faire
avancer ma
réflexion